British Prime Minister Boris Johnson is
vowed to offer millions of Hong Kong
residents a pathway to UK citizenship if
China imposes a new security law which
would clamp down on human rights the
territory was promised a high degree of
autonomy and rights under the terms of a
1997 handover treaty from Britain to
China in 1997 Hong Kong has been rocked
by anti-government protests since last
June more than 8,000 people have been
arrested but hundreds of protesters have
fled to evade prosecution the majority
of them have found refuge in Taiwan and
with Beijing pushing for a controversial
national security law for Hong Kong it
is likely that more protesters will take
the same path DWC be kong sent us this
report from Taiwan stunning after Hong
kong-style cafe used to be an everyday
event for Tom not his ruling but now
it's luxury for him and many other Hong
Kongers living in exile in Taiwan it's
just ordinary milk tea and is too new
those at his Taipei cafe that have
become remedies to ease his homesickness
it reminds me of the days when we used
to buy food from cafes like this one
during the protests and we'd finish it
during the March it's a shame that I
can't help anymore the only thing I can
do is watch the news on my cell phone
last year Tom took part in many
confrontational protests including
storming the Hong Kong legislature and
besieging University campuses he regards
himself as a frontline protester
then he fled to Taiwan in December when
police began to investigate him I fled
because I don't believe that the
judiciary will be holding fair trials
for example one man who stabbed peaceful
protesters
he was complimented by the judge for
quote showing noble qualities but we
don't see similar comments for the first
Podesta who was convicted of rioting
just because he was throwing objects I
don't trust the judges because they
appear to be biased his fear has been
intensified by Beijing's plan to enact a
national security law for Hong Kong
which has triggered global concern over
the city's remaining freedoms as many as
300 protesters like Tom have fled Hong
Kong for Taiwan over the past year
despite the lack of asylum laws
Taiwanese authorities have supported to
protest they have pledged more measures
to help settle people escaping from Hong
Kong this is the first restaurant in
Taiwan offering job opportunities to
Hong Kong protesters in excel the hope
it could be a sustainable way for them
to make their living in north terminal
project such as boutique and online
shops are underway as more protesters
are expected to come tom often plays
basketball to keep busy today he's
joined by his friend and fellow
protesters seaman seaman who also
prefers not to give his real name left
Hong Kong nearly a year ago he said the
chances of returning home are getting
slimmer day by day once the national
security law is imposed Hong Kong isn't
going to be any different from mainland
China I'm not just worried about my
personal safety I'm also worried about
my family in Hong Kong I'm concerned
that they may be intimidated or might
even get abducted by Chinese agents but
I don't plan to be in exile forever I
hope that I regain my strength one day
and be able to take back my home then
both of them will start studying in
Taiwan later this year
just like Hong Kong Thomas seaman faced
an uncertain future but at least they
are relatively safe for now that report
from CW's Phoebe Kong and she is in Hong
Kong she joins us for more in this story
hi Phoebe how welcome our Hong Kong is
like Tom in Taiwan
Ashley Hong Kong protesters and even all
the way citizens like just like Tom they
are they have one overwhelming support
in Taiwan and Taiwanese in general they
express them sympathy to protesters and
other hopefulness who happen upon like
12 months of protests on since last June
and we can see that not only ordinary
citizens it also won by passion support
from different political parties in
Taiwan despite despite the fact that
Taiwan is very politically polarized but
they have fish consensus on this issue
that they vow to help Taiwan and Hong
Kong protesters and the families
authorities also they are now setting up
a special task force to help is kind of
like Hong Kong protesters who want to
flee Hong Kong for Taiwan and they are
going to liquefy some humanitarian
believe it's like the absence of
political asylum law so in general we
see a really overwhelming support and to
the Hong Kong protest like it how long
but as China has moved to crack down on
Hong Kong particularly with this new
national security legislation how
worried is Taiwan that Beijing will
start to exert more control there as
well there has been growing anxiety like
who was China's aggression to us hi Juan
especially when China has been pushing
for its unification a like - to Taiwan
by force if necessary that according to
their words and so and based on the
passivity are between Taiwan
China and they have been growing
concerns that Taiwan okay the next
target like if Hong Kong has been
tracked down by China so on behalf of
Taiwan some honker lists are also
considering to head to other countries
in the rest of the world especially to
the west and particularly the UK the
former colonizer of Hong Kong before
1997 before Hong Kong was headed back to
China so like the UK Prime Minister
Joyce Johnson has just like even like
open statement saying that he would not
walk away from Hong Kong in China
insists on imposing the new national
security law that he will like extend
the period of of the BN o passport which
is the British National overseas
passport of Hong Kong is that to let
them to stay in the UK for Huffman's and
that will be a pathway for them to gain
the British citizenship so this can be
an other option for the Hong Kong is
like to move like in the future
alright DW so Phoebe Kong reporting for
us there thank you so much